after all the smoke settled and all the
cool hand signals were waved dr. Stephen
strange earned his spot as one of the
marvel cinematic universes best new
heroes and like in other Marvel movies
we got an extra helping of heroism in
the form of teasers for future films
after the movies ending put on your
sling ring as we explore dr. Strange's
credit scenes and just so you don't
think we're possessed by the dark powers
of Dormammu
here's our warning there are major
spoilers ahead
Thor's doctor visit it's hammer time
once again as Odin's favorite son makes
a long-awaited return after his absence
from Captain America Civil War the blond
bird doesn't look as heroic as usual
when he visits Stephen and his sanctum
after getting the s Guardian a giant
magically refilling beer strange gets
down to brass tacks he now keeps track
of major otherworldly threats to earth
which includes Thor's brother Loki who
is accompanied forward to New York to
look for their missing daddy Odin for
the sake of getting Loki off earth and
back to Asgard as soon as possible
strange decides to help the Odin sons
look for their missing patriarch we
still got a lot of questions about
what's happened in Thor's absence am I
disappointed they didn't invite me to
fight with them but we have a feeling
for Ragnarok we'll have answers and
probably lots of smashing well they're
excited
Loki's back in town the last time we saw
Loki and Thor the dark world he was
sitting on the throne of Asgard
disguised as Odin after faking his own
death Thor didn't seem to notice it was
actually Loki especially when that King
offered him the throne of Asgard which
Thor declined he even showed sadness in
describing Loki's death which shows Loki
that Thor still ultimately cares we're
not sure what happened after that did
Thor see through Loki's disguise
did the real Odin contact four or even
more crazy is it not even Thor at all
but actually Loki impersonating him to
fool dr. strange one thing's for sure
the last time Loki was in New York
things were kind of bad
next time just take a taxi dude riding a
rock and roll call tossing the sorcerer
supreme into the mix of thor ragnarok is
going to make for some interesting
events considering marvelous tease that
part of world war hulk will be mixed
into Ragnarok we can't wait to see what
happens when Doctor Strange meets dr.
banner I'm sorry I'm not that kind of
doctor
I'm not a therapist it's not my training
I don't have what the time temperament
Ragnarok director Taika Waititi
supposedly played a huge role in the
filming of the mid credit sequence so
will the master of the mystic arts
Throwdown with the Hulk it's probably
worth noting that in the comics strange
was one of the people responsible for
exiling the Hulk into space setting up
the events of the world war hulk story
in the first place just a stone's throw
away for interacting with dr. strange
inadvertently increases the chances of
bringing multiple Infinity stones
together for now strange leaves the time
stone /i of agamotto and kamar tosh
which magically connects to his new york
sanctum likewise the space stone /
tesseract is now in the vaults of Asgard
under heavy protection putting strange
and Thor's third solo film moves these
Infinity stones awfully close together
the doc will undoubtedly learn more from
Wong about the Infinity stones and
there's bound to be some kind of crazy
spell that strands could used to find
out what the other stones are just to
make sure they're all properly accounted
for and in the right hands of course
someone else is on the lookout for them
to Thanos on the hunt
Thanos has finally stepped off his
floating throne and started looking for
the Infinity stones himself which still
seems weird considering he presumably
gave Loki the staff containing the mine
stone
Thor Ragnarok isn't hitting theaters
until November 3rd 2017 and Avengers
infinity war is scheduled for May 4th
2018 so this could be the perfect
opportunity for phantoms to start
decorating his Golden Glove some fans
believe Heimdall carries the soul stone
at his armor which explains how he can
see every person in the nine realms a
Thor strange team-up could potentially
tied together half of the stones don't
be surprised if the mad Titan NAB's a
few before infinity war even begins
setting up a sequel instead of teasing
another superhero crossover the post
credits scenes established a subplot
that sets up the sorcerer Supremes
inevitable sophomore film mortal the
sorcerer who abandoned Doctor Strange at
the end of the film for his abuse at the
time stone this
johnathan Pangborn pain war was once
paralyzed but headed overseas to kumar
taj where he learned how to magically
restore his ability to walk mortal
attacks Pangborn draining him of his
magical powers and revealing a huge
change in character and a dangerous
vendetta he's decided that they're just
way to any gang sorcerers bending the
rules so it's up to him to whittle down
their numbers and when evitable crossed
paths with the likes of Wong and Stephen
strange once again mortal the villain
fans of the printed version of Doctor
Strange knew this switcheroo was coming
despite more dough being made into a
supportive character throughout most of
the film even when he parts ways with
strange it's mostly out of angry
disillusionment in the comics Baron
Mordo is a longtime antagonist to Doctor
Strange originally a student of the
ancient one Mordo tries to kill his
master after growing jealous of strange
becoming a star pupil leading to his
banishment and pursuit of the black arts
and other forbidden forms of magic in
order to achieve power of course many of
these techniques can backfire which is
kind of what happened to Casillas who's
originally only a bottom tier flunky of
mortos in the comics despite his change
in his crusade against other sorcerers
it's not like mortos gone fully evil he
could have simply killed Pangborn if he
wanted silencing the sorcerers
mortos siphoning pangborn's magical
powers for shadows as inevitable
showdown against strange his exchange
with Pangborn suggests that mortal was
coming to terms with sorcerers bending
the laws of the universe but he's likely
also believes that he's the only person
responsible enough to do the job Mordo
is out stealing sorcerers magic powers
to try and bring things back to normal
and it should lead up to one heck of a
fight at Doctor Strange - doctor
stranger thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel and watch more videos that the
one you just saw and don't forget to
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to